chacun se souvient des épisodes neigeux
de l'hiver 2010 et des automobilistes
bloqués en fin d'après midi
la leçon a été retenue et depuis deux
ans les services plus que mobilisés
pendant ces mois d'hiver
un plan vigilance a été mis en place
dans le département depuis quelques
jours les équipes de techniciens et
cadres sont mobilisés en astreinte 7
jours sur 7 et 24 heures sur 24
cette année comme l'an passé les équipes
du département vont s'appuyer sur la
participation de quinze agriculteurs
afin d'être le plus réactif possible en
zones rurales comme urbaines pendant
l'hiver dernier le département a connu
de forts épisodes neigeux
les équipes de la direction des routes
et des transports sont intervenus 104 x
et 1900 tonnes de sel ont été utilisées
dès les premiers flocons de neige les
usagers pourront consulter les dernières
alertes de circulation ou de déneigement
sur le site internet du conseil général
vous pouvez aussi vous abonner avec
votre smartphone